Hey Crazies.
It’s time for photons!
This episode was made possible by generous
supporters on Patreon.
I imagine a lot of you feel like you know
what a photon is.
It’s just a packet of energy or whatever.
But you know what happens when you assume.
You make
a mistake
sometimes.
Calling a photon a “packet of energy”
isn’t wrong.
It’s just not very useful because everything
is a packet of energy.
I have something in this box.
Can you guess what it is?
No?
Here’s a hint: It’s a collection of atoms.
Did that help?
Probably not.
Surprise!
It’s a squirrel!
My point is there’s a better way to describe
photons.
Yes, it’s a packet of energy, but it’s
the details about that energy that make it
a photon.
Hmmmm How should we tackle this?
I think the top-down approach is going to
work best.
Reductionism
Basically, it’s the idea of starting with
something normal-sized and then breaking it
up until you find the smallest pieces.
What you might call its elementary pieces.
Honestly, this is how we came up with quantum
physics in the first place, so it seems like
a great place to start.
Elementary particles are like bite-sized pieces
of something ordinary.
Kind of like how this video series comes in
bite-sized pieces of quantum physics.
It’s almost like I planned this or something.
Anyway, a photon is the smallest piece of
light.
Like you might find coming out of a flashlight
like this.
Can I have the flashlight back now?
Do you remember what happened the last time I gave a flashlight to a clone?
I wonder what this button does.
Ah! Turn it off! Turn it off!
Behave!
What if I promise to behave?
Alright, we’ll try this one more time.
Ok, back to business!!
A beam of light is one of those normal-sized
things I was talking about earlier.
It’s something we can see with our eyes.
Something the size of us.
But if we’re going to understand it like
a quantum physicist.
Physicist?
Physicist.
We need to break that beam into smaller and
smaller parts until we find something we can’t
break anymore.
Light beams are giant collections of many
electromagnetic waves.
If we focus on one of those waves, we can
see a repeating pattern.
One cycle of that pattern looks like this.
That’s one wavelength of that wave.
There really isn’t anything smaller than
this for a wave.
Is that a photon then?
No.
We have a slight problem.
Light waves can be anywhere on the EM spectrum
including the low frequency end like radio waves.
A single radio wavelength can be as large
as a small city.
I find it hard to believe a single photon
could ever be that big.
Maybe we’re looking at this all wrong.
I seem to remember saying something important
earlier.
Yes, it’s a packet of energy, but it’s
the details about that energy that make it
a photon.
Right, this isn’t about the space something
takes up.
Elementary particles like photons don’t
really have size anyway.
This is about energy.
It’s the energy we have to break into pieces.
Let’s start with a standard incandescent
light bulb.
This one is 60 watts.
That means it transforms 60 joules of electrical
energy into heat and light every second.
Incandescent bulbs are terribly inefficient
though
so only about 10% of that actually becomes
light.
When you turn it on, 6 joules of light leaves
the bulb every second
but that spreads out in all possible directions.
Eventually we’re going to see gaps between
those pieces.
Those tiny pieces of light energy are called
photons,
but the amount of energy they have is very
small.
You can calculate it using E = h f.
The “h” is Planck’s constant, which
is extremely small.
The "f" is frequency tells you what type of light it
is
and, in the visible range, it tells you color.
So the energy of a photon is a constant times
its color.
For that 60 watt light bulb, that’s 10 million
trillion photons/second.
Huuuuu, that’s a lot of photons.
Because individual photons don’t have that
much energy,
you have to get really far away to notice
the gaps between them.
Let’s say you move away from the Sun at
an unimaginable speed
and somehow manage to avoid any of Einstein’s
relativity.
Eventually, way out in space
you start to notice the Sun’s light flicker.
What you’re seeing are individual photons.
Actually, the human optic nerve doesn’t
send a signal to the brain
unless at least 9 photons arrive within 100
milliseconds.
You have to ruin everything, don’t you?
I don’t ruining things.
I make them more accurate.
Alright, so humans can’t see individual
photons, but that actually explains a few
things.
If you move away from the Sun like we did
earlier
you can’t see the flicker of the photons,
so at about 750 light years
the Sun’s light will just fade away into
the blackness of space.
That’s why the night sky is mostly black
lit by just a few nearby stars.
The rest of the photons are just too infrequent
for us to see.
So, what the heck is photon?
Right! Right!
Stay focused, Nick!
There are a lot of little packets of energy
floating around the universe.
What makes some of them photons is all in
the details, my dear crazies.
Photons have a specific set of properties
that make them photons.
A charge of zero,
a spin of 1 with two possible orientations,
and, lastly, a rest mass of zero,
which makes many things about photons possible.
Their speed of almost 300 million meters per second.
Their energy being proportional to their momentum
and their inability to experience time or space.
Any little packet of energy with those properties
is, by definition, a photon.
So, got any questions?
Please ask in the comments.
Thanks for liking and sharing this video.
Don’t forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us.
And, from one packet-of-energy to another,
remember, it’s ok to be a little crazy.
Several people asked about the Red/Blue kind
of 3D glasses.
One.
They’re not Red and Blue.
They’re Red and Cyan.
because those are opposite colors.
Together, they make white.
Two. They use color filters to block one of the
images instead of using polarizers
so they don’t really work on color images
only black & white ones.
Anyway, crazies, thanks for watching!